yeah I can't wrap my mind it's kind of
odd no it's totally odd is that warfare
or is that just an act of God it somehow
just happened I don't that's a good
that's a good question it's a really
good question Ezard
is there email traffic that would prove
one way or the other
yes there is Arthur government cablegram
traffic and things and that would be one
way or the other
yes there is are there are letters are
there doctors some of the doctors are
still alive most of them have been
killed already who were there at the
Ground Zero when pandemic started oh so
from her dad though that's kind of odd
when you say now I'm not a conspiracy
person I want to see it black and white
I want to see the proof and there is
proof out there to prove this one way or
the other so I don't want to say one way
or the other this is not active work but
it could be I can't prove it one way or
the other I'd like to know one way or
the other so let's do the data yeah it's
to me it's to me it's just scary I'm not
really a big conspiracy person either
but when you hear stuff like that it
just you can't help but just look deeper
into it and try to figure out what
happened and what where shits going
wrong well if you want to think about
the future of warfare you should be
investing in you know ships and bombs
and the big stuff for nuclear nuclear
bombs and all the other stuff the
stockpiles of everything we had to blow
stuff from destroy that's not the future
of warfare the future of warfare is
cyber and that's why I'm making a Space
Command the first thing we do what we
made a Space Command why would you made
a cyber command at the same level and
Joint Chiefs of Staff because that's
where it's all and so while electronics
it's all about that then after a cyber
command should have been like an MVC
command should have been nuclear bomb
out of chemical and all the other stuff
command after cyber space would be third
after cyber and after a MVC or E or MVC
burn chemical radiological or biological
so the Sivir in command is if I was
nation I wanted to take over let's say
let's say New York City you wanted your
New York State wanted to take her from
New York City because New York State is
just so sick of New York City mm-hmm
so if we just drop a couple of nuclear
bombs in New York City and flat net well
we destroy it all the infrastructure we
destroyed all of the power plants all
the dams all the water everything else
and nobody can live within a hundred
square miles of where all those bombs
dropped right but what if we let
biological virus into the city and it's
it's half life of the biological that
we've released into the city had a
half-life of like let's say two months
and it killed off 80% of the population
you would depopulate entire city and
then a city would be clean in two months
that you could move in and take over not
a building fell not a bomb not a nothing
just two just got rid of all the people
mm-hmm how how good would that warfare
be for a nation and wanted to take over
another nation you would have to worry
about and in the infrastructure you just
go in there and clean up a little bit
get rid of all that and within two
months you can move in yeah look at the
cost savings it would be in warfare not
to take a building down with a bomb but
just to get rid of all the people on it
mm-hmm
yeah it really does seem to I mean guns
and bombs are all you have now is going
to be cyber warfare and biological
chemical warfare it's all that's left
what and then all these then only can
use the delivery systems and delivery
systems is all by drone anyway so all
you need is some drone pilots if you're
good with Xbox and then you're a drone
pilot you can deliver the bottle out to
come and do whatever you want from your
CD you can just sit there play the game
okay drops and you only need to drop
them you just crash your UAV and it's a
targets fly you on have you ever messed
with those new drones those DJI phantom
drones that have the cameras on them
have you ever messed around with those
the ones you can buy it like Walmart
well I started flying drones in 1999
some of the first drones that were ever
you as a militarized I was one of the
first person to do a call for fire with
mortar strikes out of drone so I have my
little drone I was flying
duquan for fire hitting mortars so yeah
I it was basically trailblazing drone
technology in the late 90s early 2000
before 9/11 and when you launched your
how did you launch that drone we did a
hand launch you throw him in the air we
did catapult launches okay
we also would take them off from runways
- so I've flown drones you know the big
ones the dual prop single prop the
turboprop the big ones and small ones
the micro drones of your little ones and
the real big ones and we did explosives
on the drones we did cameras we did
chemical biological testing devices on
the drones so we could fly them through
an area and it was contaminated we were
purposely crash it out in the ocean if
it showed back that was not contaminated
we could bring it back and land it
because basically you craft something to
Yoshi oh she cleans it out no matter
what it is
so you don't want to bring it back if it
has stuff on it so you just crash it
purposely because it's got affected I
had stuff on it don't bring it back what
were you what SEAL team were you on when
you were involved in the raid of
Saddam's palace can you talk about that
I was on a SEAL team and we've rated a
lot of palaces as we were going through
there and we stayed in this hangar and
it was all shot if it was bullet ridden
hangar that was uh it was pretty cool
little hangar but uh and we also stayed
in a place called the V VIP lounge for
the Baghdad Airport so I will say those
two things a shot-up hanger and a VVIP
lounge that's about all I would say and
if you know those areas and you know I
was working with but um I know the part
of your book where you're talking about
you guys were going down a river near
the palace and you had to fly Shatt
al-arab i craft two UAV on that river
and i really I still have nightmares
about crashing UAVs that caused problems
I screwed up and I still have like
really big problems with that screw-up
like when I make mistakes I own them I
say hey I messed up right I crashed if
he and I and I
and cost lives I cost us not to have the
Intel we needed and I don't know how
many people I could have say if I didn't
crash that one UAV so huh haunts me it
haunts you but I think it it speaks
volumes that you're able to own up to it
because honestly I mean people that are
able to fail and live with it and talk
about it and share it with people that
is what enables you to succeed is to be
able to fail and fail and fail and be
okay you're gonna miss you're gonna miss
a dozen shots but you're still gonna
make lots and lots of game-winning shots
yeah and I think that spoke volumes that
really stuck with me in your book I mean
we all shed and this is here's an
example of somebody I if I did it if I
messed up
I'll admit and I've definitely had my
share of screw-ups and sometimes it
takes a long time to realize how bad
you're screwing up and when you finally
realize it and then you're like waltz
it's kind of too late now we just do on
it and I would stew on stuff because I
get so exact and I've stood and I've
messed up and then I stood on it and I
finally realized and I was like well
it's too late now I wish I could go back
in time and fix that I would I would
immediately say I've screwed up and you
know this is what I'm gonna do to make
up for my screw-up and let's get back
into business that's fit let's fix it
and let's drive home get better hats I
wish I could have done that earlier you
know it would have been better there
here's an example of somebody who's
screwed up and never owned up to it and
it caused someone here it is if you're a
Navy captain on an aircraft carrier
you're that you're the captain you're
the skipper there's an admiral of above
you who's running a carrier battle group
but running that [ __ ] of the day-to-day
running in every person on ship 4,000
people who are working that ship that oh
six that captain he's the guy he's in
charge now let's say you had a young
seaman this young kid he's 19 years old
and he's away from home he's new in the
Navy's really is tough and his kid is
having
you know some issues and he's not
getting along with a lot of people he's
doing whatever he's a happy kid man a
kid I have a video of the kid from a day
before the incident where he was like
he's mopping the hallway he's dancing
around he's dancing music he's just a 19
year old kid the captain here is that
this kid has some suicide ideation says
he's really he's really upset the
captain calls a captain's call for the
whole division and has like 500 peoples
lined up in the hangar decks and he
starts making fun of the kid in front of
everybody by name to the entire 500
people standing there makes fun of the
kid because the kid is weak because the
kid is thinking about committing suicide
he's just faking it he doesn't know it
and a captain the leader of that ship is
making fun of this kid by name in front
of 500 of his peers then the kid
attempts suicide on the ship and didn't
happen the captain further makes fun of
him and puts him in the Brig and then
the kid gets sent to the brig and hang
himself with his shoelaces in the brig
and is dead now do you think that
captain was punished or the captain
admitted that hey you know it was in
front of 500 people I made fun of the
kid I didn't really understand where is
it I'm not a psychiatrist I don't know
did the captain say any that know that
captain got promoted to Admiral and that
kid is dead who killed himself
and as an organization if you can see
that do you see the bottle in that mug
kick strong pick strong yeah so look up
the hashtag hashtag hashtag hick strong
and look out the Hicks strong org I
think it is will tell you the whole
story as you tell you about the mother
and a father who makes these mugs
they're called hug mugs because a mother
and father of that young semen you know
Hicks who just breaks my heart so Mike
and Jolie are the parents and and
they're at my house they gave me this
mug because they asked all the sailors
on the ship who were friends with her
son before to he'll kill himself they
said what could we have done and all
that all the kids were like to the
parents is that you couldn't have done
anything it was the captain ridiculed
your son and friend everybody and like
everything was going on they talked
about it all they said well is there
anything that if you had you know what
would you want and a lot of sailors said
we just if just sometimes just give a
hug man give support and she said and I
said yes drink coffee all the time but
what if I made a hug mug hmm what if we
made hug mugs and it says hug mug on the
handle that you have this big mug you
drinking coffee out of this made
custom-made for me she made this one for
me with his big sunflower on it and the
other side says courageous to remind me
every day that were all courageous so
every morning I drink coffee
it's Jolie Hicks a wonderful lady she
gives me a hug every morning I drink
coffee cuz I have a mug I'm gonna drink
a hug mom I'm gonna drink I'm gonna get
a hug right now
that's beautiful
[Music]
[Laughter]